[Music]
the witcher's jennifer of wengerberg has
a brutal and generally unforgiving life
originally cursed and ostracized by her
community for her elfish blood jennifer
is further outcasted from society thanks
to being born with a hunchback and an
awkward gait her family later sells her
to the passing mage to saya the
headmistress of aratuza an academy for
female mages tessaya senses an untapped
potential in the brow beaten yennefer
though her new life at aratuza is at
first little better than the one she had
ambitious to a fault in craving great
power jennifer uses a combination of
guile intimidation and cunning in season
1 to finally learn to use magic while at
the same time transforming her visage to
become beautiful though at great
personal cost season 2 picks up after
jennifer taps into the forbidden magic
of fire which saves the day and stops
the nilfgaardian advance but leaves her
bereft of the magic that defines so much
of her existence once again jennifer is
put in a place where she is willing to
do anything to get her power back it all
sets the stage for a season 2 scene that
had even the biggest yennefer fans
worried about how the show is handling
her character the second episode of
season 2 care morin sees jennifer
frangilla and francesca invoke a
supposedly ancient elfish deity but when
they do the apparition conjured whisks
the three away and offers each of them
their heart's desire though it's implied
there will be a cost
that's your play it's rather desperate
you're the desperate one young man
love the most
both frangilla and francesca agree but
jennifer initially refuses however
yennefer is later captured and about to
be executed when she invokes a litany
that summons the deathless mother who
promises to return magic to yennefer in
exchange for a young girl whom she
doesn't recognize jennifer reluctantly
agrees and the desperation in her eyes
is palpable this is a pretty big
sacrifice that would make even the
evilest person wins but jennifer is
willing to do anything at this point in
season 2. she eventually comes across
her target in a twist of fate it turns
out to be geralt's adoptive child siri
the deathless mother feeds off pain and
suffering and had jennifer sacrificed
siri there would have been tremendous
pain for both geralt and herself to a
degree jennifer's action shouldn't come
as too much of a surprise in season one
audiences saw how yennefer reacts to a
world that treats her with cruelty
before she transforms after she changes
what the physical traits society wants
shunder for now fixed she goes on to
embrace her power as a sorceress using
her magic for both good and ill
jennifer's shocking turn however brief
left fans of the witch are polarized her
ability to toe the line between hiro and
villain is intriguing and part of what
makes her such a complex and compelling
character
it was this complex nature that had fans
reacting right and left on reddit many
expressed how upset they were with this
scene and its implications on her
character arc in season 2. on the
subreddit r netflix witcher one redditor
wrote really disappointed in yen this
season and i thought she was one of the
best characters in season one i was
really looking forward to her teaching
siri about magic but that storyline was
basically compressed into two or three
scenes when they were writing to sintra
also did not like that yen was planning
to sacrifice siri to get her powers back
this really puts a weird strain on their
relationship from here on out another
user offered a rebuttal saying but then
yan warned siri and later sacrificed
herself for her plus geralt loves her
meanwhile ian is so impressed and
enamored by siri that all will be soon
forgotten it's hard to hate someone who
actively and obviously adores you a
different poster acknowledged that the
show develops jennifer and series
dynamic differently than the way it
develops in andre sapkowski's the
witcher books there jennifer has a more
friendly almost maternal stance and
helps siri learn about her magic as we
see in this particularly divisive season
2 scene jennifer's actions lay the
foundation for a different tone in her
relationship with siri as the reddit
user wrote in the show she doesn't know
siri and she's desperate to get her
powers people make stupid decisions when
they're desperate so i get what they
were trying to do here would i have
preferred if they kept the book version
yes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you